well during today's televised
immigration talks Senator Lindsey Graham
joked about how the final daca deal will
likely infuriate those opposed to
amnesty including people on this channel
Lindsey Graham Misti Lindsey gomez you
name every name you want to give to me
it's been assigned to me and I'm still
standing the people of South Carolina
want a result how could I get elected
I've been for a pathway to citizenship
for 11 million people because I have no
animosity toward them I don't want
crooks I don't want bad hombres I want
to get a merit-based immigration system
to make sure we can succeed in the 21st
century I'm willing to be more than fair
to the 11 million I just don't want to
do this every 20 years now we made the
decision mr. president not to do it
comprehensively I think that's a smart
decision but a hard decision we passed
three comprehensive bills out of the
Senate with over 65 votes they go to the
house and die and I'm not being
disparaging to my house colleagues this
is stuff politics if you're a Republican
House member turning on the radio to my
Democratic friends thanks for coming to
resist movement hates this guy they
don't want him to be successful at all
you turn on Fox News and I can hear the
drumbeat coming right-wing radio and TV
talk show hosts are going to beat the
crap out of us because it's gonna be
amnesty all over again
senator Graham instantly instantly
turned down our request to come on
tonight and explain himself so that
virtually every Republican we reached
out to congressman Rodney Davis of New
Jersey though a rather of Illinois said
yes and we're grateful that he did he
joins us tonight Congress Thanks coming
up thanks for having me on Tucker so it
I understand the concern about daca
recipients some of whom you know didn't
choose to come here and they're stuck
here now it's a sticky situation I get
it but if you're creating a hierarchy of
concerns why is this some more pressing
matter than say the opioid crisis or the
rise in health care education costs well
I think for American citizens well thank
you Tucker I actually think those two
issues is somewhat related the president
and many of us have said we'd like to
get a daca fix we want to make sure that
the president continues to have the
opportunity to show leadership like he
has on such a very difficult issue and
we can also implement some Republican
immigration reforms border security
measures he mentioned the opioid crisis
you talk to any law enforcement official
in my district in central Illinois they
will tell you the scourge of heroin and
ice are coming through our southern
border we need some physical structures
down there let's let the Border Patrol
decide where they go for sure I mean
that sounds sensible but the the core of
this the centerpiece the debate really
is over giving amnesty to daca
recipients how does that help American
citizens how does help any of your
voters it wouldn't seem to help any of
them
well first off let's take a step back
let's let's see what comes of this
meeting obviously again I thought the
president showed great leadership and a
very difficult issue that he's willing
to take a stand on let's actually see
what the legislative language looks like
let's see if there's any bipartisan
agreement but at the end at the end of
the day let's try and solve a problem
that the president asked us to solve
when he got rid of an unconstitutional
executive action right now I get it and
it's it's a tough place and it was a
trap laid by the previous administration
and Republicans of course walked right
into it
but I get if you take three steps back
it seems a little bit weird that we're
about to shut down the government over
legalizing illegal aliens when 60,000
Americans died last year of drug Odie's
and no one can afford college and
there's like a lot of bad things going
on in the country but the concern if you
legal aliens is put to the very top of
the list can you see why people would be
kind of bewildered by that well the only
ones talking about shutting down the
government over this issue are the
Democrats it's not the Republicans we
want to have a common-sense solution
that includes some border security
measures and they're the ones that want
to see this linked to a government
shutdown to a writing vote let's have a
let's have a great meeting like the
President did today let's see what the
end results are let's see if Senator
Durbin and the rest of the Democrats
come out after this meeting and still
want to negotiate a border security
measure that includes some physical
structures let's see what comes of this
meeting before we we even see the
legislation that comes out and see the
end result of that but if the
Republicans accept a deal that doesn't
include universally verify that doesn't
end chain migration and the diversity
lottery and build a wall why would
anybody ever vote Republican again
honestly well I think again this is our
opportunity if you have ideas that are
Republican immigration reforms the
president clearly said now's the
time to put those ideas on the table
these are issues that we've been talking
about in our conference for years as a
matter of fact you know most of the Ilia
dual immigration in this country doesn't
even come through our southern border it
comes through airports people
overstaying their visas who were here
legally and we don't have any biometric
capability to be able to track them and
figure out where they've gone would you
support a deal that doesn't end chain
migration for daca recipients you know
again let's see what the bill looks like
because I think these are some of the
priorities that the president has
clearly laid out in the past and I
believe will clearly lay out with
Republican support as we look ahead to
the next few days yeah this is making me
nervous
congressman thanks a lot for coming on I
appreciate it Thank You Tucker